hello folks okay well so I did a video
there's a trailer video on the venom
trailer yesterday and in there I said
one of the lines came across as a bit
cheesy just set it in passing didn't
think much of it a lot of people took it
very seriously and one of the lines I
thought was cheesy is taken directly
from the comic book anything to tell now
I've been operating on the assumption
that if you translate something from say
a comic book to the big screen that's
great but it has to translate well to
the strings not everything that's
written not everything that's in a comic
book translates well to a movie but I've
been informed in the comment section of
my last video no one can argue that if
it's translated from the source material
at all on the basis that is translated
from the source material that is pulled
from the comic book it is automatically
good which changes everything I thought
I knew about what is good and what it's
not in an adaptation I'd like to issue a
few apologies here one in particular
first of all we're gonna start out with
venom I'm sorry about what I said about
your cheesy lines in the movie I thought
that the line that's from the 90s that
might come across as cheesy in a movie
maybe you should omit it for the movie
or maybe change it subtly but apparently
not apparently on the basis that it's
pulled from the comic book that is what
makes it good and I didn't know you said
that in a comic book I just don't have
your comic books memorized so for that I
apologize but my next apology has to be
for the van Damme street fighter I mean
I always thought the dialogue in that
movie was completely cheesy and some of
its pulled directly from the game are
you man enough to fight with me anyone
no opposes me will be this joy that's
good because it's pulled from the source
material I feel like I have more
apologies to make not gonna get to them
all but I feel like this is a good start
so here we go I apologize first to
Batman for giving him [ __ ] for killing
people in Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice Batman and the comic books in
fact has killed people so Batman killing
people in Batman vs. Superman dawn of
Justice is simply accurate to the source
material ergo it is good I apologize
next to Jim Carrey's Riddler and Batman
Forever your zany physical comedy is an
accurate representation of your
character and the source material I also
want to apologize to Jim Carrey Riddler
about the costume rather my comments
about his costume I always saw the gee
Karrie Riddler spandex tights costume as
cheesy but it is pulled from source
material so sorry for all the times I
called it corny I now apologize to
Batman vs Superman dawn of justice for
the fact that a lot of people a lot of
us say Batman V Superman dawn of Justice
though V is supposed to represent the
term versus as seen in the show American
crime story the people versus OJ Simpson
where vs. is represented by the same V
that Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice
has the People vs OJ Simpson I'm sorry
we just don't take the time to say
versus when we probably should I
apologize to the entire Twilight Saga
here angsty teen [ __ ] dramas simply
representative of your source material
in that you did a fine job
I also apologize to the Fifty Shades
trilogy your horrendous dialogue could
only represent those abominations of
literature I also apologize to the human
race for calling the Fifty Shades books
literature but just now I would also
like to offer a big sincere apology to
turbo a Power Rangers movie for me ever
saying as a negative you look like the
TV show when in reality you looking like
the TV show is simply you showing your
source material I'm sorry - doomsday in
Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice for
saying as a negative you were just
thrown into the last acts simply to
create a fight and make a fight happen
when doomsday essentially came into the
comic books to make a fight happen with
Superman so right there though his
creation in Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice may have been different his
point in simply being there for a fight
was accurate to the source material I'm
so sorry to Wolverine for all the [ __ ]
I've given you about the bum claws I've
never liked the bone claws but bone
claws are simply accurate representation
of the source material post 1993 I
sincerely apologize - Star Wars Star
Wars has indeed and in fact always been
created for kids the fact that kids were
a little more hardcore and maybe
cerebral in the 70s and 80s that is no
fault of yours I am so sorry for ripping
on Batman and Robin by saying it looks
like a [ __ ] toy commercial Batman and
Robin you were made to sell toys you
looked like a toy commercial ergo you
succeeded in what you set out to do so
props you know I just have more love to
give the van dem street fighter I've
caused so much pain I apologize
VanDam streetfighter for thinking that
everyone's snapping into their wind pose
at the end of the movie was cheesy the
heroes won thus them snapping into their
wind pose from the game is simply
accurate representation of the game the
source material plus it is good
I'm sorry also the Mortal Kombat for
thinking it absurd and cheesy at the
prospect of Johnny Cage having an
unfolded on creased headshot in his
pocket that he then laid down with an
autograph on it after he beats scorpion
when he does do that in the game so it's
an accurate representation of the source
material shame on you Jurassic Park
movie really nothing like your source
material in fact you're a representation
of the source material innately is good
is inaccurate representation innately
bad internet I don't know what to think
without you I'm also sorry too Mortal
Kombat annihilation for saying Johnny
Cage went out like a punk at the
beginning of the movie where an old
Laura Johnny Cage did get killed in Shao
Kahn's invasion so it is accurate to the
source material kind of sidestep in
movies for a second but I have to give a
heartfelt sincere apology to Twitter I
am sorry Twitter for saying that you are
a social dumpster fire when you're
simply accurately representing your
source material which is Satan's [ __ ]
[ __ ] for these next couple I'm gonna
speak on behalf of a lot of fans maybe I
didn't have as much of a problem with
this but maybe a lot of people did so on
behalf of you who had a problem with
these next couple I will speak for you
because you'll want in on this trust me
you will on behalf of fans I'm sorry to
the DC EU and DC movies and other DC
universes are creating parallel to the
DC EU that aren't really tied to the DC
EU so I may find it confusing but
creating other universes that aren't
tied to other universes that's just how
comic-book universes work thus the
cinematic universe is being created our
accurate representations of the source
material comic-book universes and on
behalf of many fans everywhere I am
sorry Harley Quinn that you got so much
[ __ ] for going back to the Joker your
abusive boyfriend but it is
representative of your character and
your source material oh it was a few of
them mommy few apologies I had to make
but I had to do it you know why because
I just my eyes have been opened
something comes across as cheesy in a
movie look into it if it comes directly
from source material it just can't be
cheesy now yes as you've seen an assess
by now if we're giving venom a pass if
we give one thing a pass that give
everything else have passed - it's only
fair why so for you I mean you're out
there we've all given things [ __ ] things
that are derived from source material
what do you have to apologize for
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and is always
a bit like what you've seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more
[Music]